What difference between biological and
you own that works and artificial neural
networks is most mysterious,
captivating,
and profound for you.
First of all,
there's so much we don't know about
biological neural networks and that's
very mysterious and captivating because
maybe it holds the key to improving
artificial neural networks.
One of the things I studied recently as
something that we don't know how
biological neural networks do but would
be really useful for artificial ones is
the ability to do credit assignment
through very long time spans.
There are things that we can in
principle do with artificial neural
nets,
but it's not very convenient and it's
not biologically plausible.
And this mismatch and think this kind of
mismatch.
Maybe an interesting thing to study to a
understand better how brains my duties
things because we don't have good
corresponding theories with artificial
neural nets and B,
maybe provide new ideas that we could
explore about,
um,
things like brain do differently and
that we could incorporate in artificial
neural nets.
So let's break
credit assignment up a little bit.
It's a beautifully technical term,
but it can incorporate so many things.
So is it more on the rnn memory side
that thinking like that or is it
something about knowledge building up
common sense knowledge over time,
or is it more in the reinforcement
learning sense that you're picking up
rewards over time for a particular
charge you a certain kinds of goals?
I was thinking more about the first two
meetings whereby we store all kinds of
memories,
episodic memories in our brain,
which we can access later in order to
help us both infor causes of things that
we are observing now and assign credit
to decisions or interpretations we came
up with a while ago when you know those
memories were stored and then we can
change the way we would have reacted or
interpreted things in the past.
And now that's credit assignment used
for learning.
So in which way do you think
artificial neural networks,
the current Lstm,
the current architectures are not able
to capture
the.
Presumably you're,
you're thinking of very longterm.
Yes.
So current recurrent nets are doing a
fairly good jobs for sequences,
dozens or hundreds of time steps and
then it gets harder and harder and
depending on what you have to remember
and so on as you consider longer
durations.
Whereas humans seem to be able to do
credit assignment to essentially
arbitrary times.
Like I,
I could remember something I did last
year and now because I see some new
evidence,
I'm gonna change my mind about the way I
was thinking last year and hopefully not
do the same mistake again.
I think a big part of that,
it's probably forgetting your only
remembering the really important things
that's very efficient for getting.
Yes.
So there's a selection of what we
remember and I think they're a really
cool connection to higher level
cognition here regarding consciousness
deciding and any emotions that sort of
deciding what comes to consciousness and
what gets stored in memory,
which,
which are not trivial either.
So you've been at the forefront there
all along.
Showing some of the amazing things that
neural networks,
deep neural networks can do in the field
of artificial intelligence is just
broadly in all kinds of applications.
But uh,
we can talk about that forever.
But what in your view,
because we're thinking towards the
future,
is the weakest aspect of the way deep
neural networks represent the world.
What is the,
what is in your view is missing?
So currently current
state of the art neural nets trained on
large quantities of images or texts have
some level of understanding of what
explains those datasets,
but it's very basic.
It's,
it's very low level and it's not nearly
as robust and abstract and general as
our understanding.
Okay.
So that doesn't tell us how to fix
things,
but I think it encourages us to think
about how we can maybe train our neural
nets differently so that they would
focus,
for example,
on causal explanation is something that
we don't do currently with neural net
training.
Also,
one thing I'll talk about in my talk
this afternoon is instead of learning
separately from images and videos on one
hand and from texts,
on the other hand,
we need to do a better job of jointly
learning about language and about the
world to which it refers so that both
sides can help each other.
We need to have good world models in,
in our neural nets for them to really
understand sentences which talk about
what's going on in the world and I think
we need language input to help provide
clues about what the high level concepts
like semantic concepts should be
represented at the top levels of these
neural nets.
In fact,
there is evidence that the purely
unsupervised learning of representations
doesn't give rise to high level
representations that are as powerful as
the ones we're getting from supervised
learning.
And so the,
the,
the clues were getting just with the
labels.
Not even sentences is already very
powerful.
Do you think that's an architecture
challenge or is it a Dataset challenge?
Neither.
A.
I'm tempted to just end it there.
Can you elaborate?
Uh,
of course,
data sets on architectures are something
you want to always play with,
but,
but I think the crucial thing is more
the training objectives,
the training frameworks,
for example,
going from passive observation of data
to more active agents,
which I'm a learn by intervening in the
world,
uh,
the relationships between causes and
effects,
the sort of objective functions which
could be important to allow the,
the highest level,
uh,
explanations to,
to,
to rise from the learning,
which I don't think we have now a kinds
of objective functions which could be
used to,
uh,
reward exploration,
the right kind of exploration to these
kinds of questions are neither in the
Dataset nor,
and the architecture,
but more in how we learn under what
objectives and so on.
Yeah,
that's a fruit.
You mentioned in several contexts.
The idea sort of the way children learn,
they interact with objects of the world.
And it seems a fascinating because in
some sense,
except with some cases in reinforcement
learning,
that idea is not part of the learning
process in artificial neural networks.
So it's almost like,
do you envision something like an
objective function saying,
you know what,
if you poke this object in this kind of
way will be really helpful for me at to
four further further learn sort of
almost guiding some aspect of learning.
Right,
right.
So I was talking to Rebecca Saxe just an
hour ago and she was talking about lots
and lots of evidence from a infants seem
to clearly take what interests them in a
directed way.
And so they're not passive learners.
They,
they focus their attention on aspects of
the world which are most interesting,
surprising in,
in a non trivial way that makes them
change their theories of the world.
So,
uh,
that's a fascinating view of the future
progress.
But on a,
on a more maybe boring
a question,
do you think going deeper and larger.
So do you think just increasing the size
of the things that have been increasing
a lot in the past few years?
We'll,
we'll also make significant progress.
So some of the representational issues
that you mentioned,
that they're kind of shallow in some
sense.
Oh,
prior and a sense of abstraction.
Abstract in the sense of abstraction,
they're not getting some.
I don't think that having more,
more depth in the network in the sense
of instead of 100 layers we have 10,000
is going to solve our problem.
You don't think so?
No.
Is that obvious to you?
Yes.
What is clear to me is that engineers
and companies and labs,
a Grad students will continue to tune
architectures and explore all kinds of
tweaks to make the current state of the
arts that he ever slightly better.
Right.
But I don't think that's going to be
nearly enough.
I think we need some fairly drastic
changes in the way that we're
considering learning to achieve the goal
that these learners actually understand
in a deep way the environment in which
they are,
uh,
you know,
observing and acting.
But I,
I guess,
uh,
I was trying to ask a question is more
interesting than just more layers is
basically once you figure out a way to
learn to interacting,
how many parameters does it take to
store that information?
So I think our brain is quite bigger
than most neural networks.
Right,
right.
Oh,
I see.
What you mean,
I'll I,
I'm with you there.
So I agree that in order to build you'll
nets with a kind of a broad knowledge of
the world.
The typical adult humans have probably
the kind of computing power we have now.
He's going to be insufficient.
So far.
The good news is there are hardware
companies building,
you'll net chips and so it's gonna get
better.
However,
the good news in a way,
which is also a bad news,
is that even our state of the art deep
learning methods fail to learn models
that understand even very simple
environments like some grid worlds that
we have built.
Even these fairly environments.
I mean,
of course if you trim them with enough
examples,
eventually they get it,
but it's just like instead of what,
instead of what humans might need,
just a dozens of examples of these
things,
we'll need millions,
right?
For very,
very,
very simple tasks.
And so I think there's an opportunity
for academics who don't have the kind of
computing power that say Google has to
do really important and exciting
research to advance the state of the art
in training frameworks,
learning models,
uh,
agent learning in even simple
environments that are synthetic that
seemed trivial,
but yet current machine learning fails
on.
We talked about priors and common sense
knowledge.
It seems like a,
we humans take a lot of knowledge for
granted.
Uh,
so what's your view of these priors of
forming this broad view of the world,
this accumulation of information and how
we can teach and your networks are
learning systems to pick that knowledge
up.
So knowledge,
you know,
for awhile the artificial intelligence
maybe in the 80 [inaudible] like there's
a time or knowledge representation,
knowledge acquisition expert systems,
symbolic ai was the view was an
interesting problem set to solve.
And it was kind of put on hold a little
bit.
It seems like because it doesn't work,
it doesn't work.
That's right.
But that's right.
But the goals of that remain important.
Yes.
Remain important.
And how do you think those goals can be
addressed?
So first of all,
I believe that one reason why the
classical expert systems approach failed
is because a lot of the knowledge we
have.
So you talked about common sense
intuition.
Um,
there's a lot of knowledge like this
which is not consciously accessible.
There are lots of decisions we're taking
that we can really explain even if
sometimes we make up a story and that
knowledge is also necessary for machines
to,
to take good decisions.
And that knowledge is hard to codify and
expert systems,
rule based systems and classical ai
formalism.
And there are other issues of course
with the old I like,
I'm not really good ways of handling
uncertainty.
I would say something more subtle,
which we understand better now,
but I think still isn't enough in the
minds of people.
There's something really powerful that
comes from distributed representations.
The thing that really makes neural nets
work so well and it's hard to replicate
that kind of power in symbolic world.
The knowledge in an expert systems and
so on is nicely decomposed into like a
bunch of rules.
Whereas if you think about a new net,
it's the opposite.
You have this big blob of parameters
which work intensely together to are
presented everything the network knows
and it's not sufficiently factorized and
so I think this is one of the weaknesses
of current neural nets that we have to
take lessons from classical ai in order
to bring in another kind of composition,
let which is common in language for
example,
and in these rules,
but that isn't so native to neural nets
and on that line of thinking
disentangled representations.
Yes,
so,
so when you connect with disentangled
representations,
if you might,
if you don't mind it.
So for many years I've thought and I
still believe that it's really important
that we come up with learning algorithms
either unsupervised or supervised,
but reinforcement,
whatever that builds representations in
which the important factors,
hopefully causal factors are nicely
separated and easy to pick up from the
representation.
So that's the idea of disentangled
representations.
It says transform the data into a space
where everything becomes easy.
We can maybe just learn with linear
models about the things we care about.
And I still think this is important,
but I think this is missing out on a
very important ingredient which
classical ai systems can remind us of.
So let's say we have these,
these integral presentation,
you still need to learn about the
relationships between the variables,
those high level semantic variables.
They're not going to be independent.
I mean this is like too much of a.
An assumption they're going to have some
interesting relationships that allow us
to predict things in the future to
explain what happened in the past.
The kind of knowledge about those
relationships in a classical ai system
is encoded in the rules like rule is
just like a little piece of knowledge
that says,
oh,
I have these two,
three,
four variables that are linked in this
interesting way.
Then I can say something about one or
two of them given a couple of others.
Right?
In addition to design,
tangling the,
the elements of the representation which
are like the variables in a rule based
system,
you also need to disentangle the,
the mechanisms that relate those
variables to each other.
So like the rules.
So the rules are neatly separated.
And I,
each rule is,
you know,
living on his own and when I,
I changed a rule because I'm learning a,
it doesn't need to break other roles,
whereas current neural nets for example,
are very sensitive to what's called
catastrophic forgetting,
where,
uh,
after I've learned some things and then
they're learn new things,
they can destroy the old things that I
had learned,
right?
If the knowledge was better factorized
and separated,
disentangled,
then you would avoid a lot of that.
Now you can't do this in the sensory
domain,
but what do you mean?
Like in Pixel space.
But,
but my idea is that when you project the
data and the right semantic space,
it becomes possible to now represent
this extra knowledge beyond the
transformation from input to
representations,
which is how representations act on each
other and predict the future and so on,
in a way that can be neatly
disentangled.
So now it's the rules that are
disentangled from each other and not
just the variables that are disentangled
from each other.
And you draw a distinction between
semantic space and pixel needs to be an
architectural difference or.
Well,
yeah.
So,
so there's the sensory space like
pixels,
which where everything is entangled,
the,
the information like the variables are
completely interdependent in very
complicated ways and also computation
like the,
it's not just variables,
it's also how they are related to each
other as is all intertwined.
But,
but I,
I'm hypothesizing that in the right high
level representation space,
both the variables and how they relate
to each other can be disentangled and
that will provide a lot of
generalization.
Power.
Generalization power.
Yes.
A distribution of the test set you
assume to be the same as the
distribution of the training set.
Right.
This is where current machine learning
is too weak.
It doesn't tell us anything is not able
to tell us anything about how our neural
nets say are going to generalize to a
new distribution.
And,
and you know,
people may think,
well,
but there's nothing we can say if we
don't know what the new distribution
will be.
The truth is humans are able to
generalize to new distributions how
we're able to do that.
So because there is something,
these new distributions,
even though they could look very
different from the distributions,
they have things in common.
So let me give you a concrete example.
You read a science fiction novel,
the science fiction novel maybe you
know,
brings you in some other planet where
things look very different on the
surface,
but it's still the same laws of physics.
Right?
And so you can read the book and You
understand what's going on.
So the distribution is very different,
but because you can transport a lot of
the knowledge you had from Earth about
the underlying cause and effect
relationships and physical encounters,
isms and all that,
and maybe even social interactions,
you can now make sense of what is going
on on this planet where like visually
for example,
things are totally different.
Taking the analogy and distorting
it.
That's enter a science,
science fiction world of say a space
odyssey 2001 with how?
Yeah,
or,
or maybe,
uh,
which is probably one of my favorite ai
movie's and then to it.
And then there's another one that a lot
of people love that.
It may be a little bit outside of the Ai
Community is x Mokena.
I don't know if you've seen it in a
bottle.
What are your views on that movie?
Does it,
does,
are you able to enjoy the things I like
and things I hate.
So maybe you could talk about that in
the context of a question I want to ask,
which is a,
there's quite a large community of
people from different backgrounds often
outside of ai who are concerned about
existential threat of artificial
intelligence.
Right?
And you've seen this community develop
overtime,
you've seen you have a perspective.
So,
uh,
what,
what do you think is the best way to
talk about Ai Safety?
To think about it,
to have discourse about it within ai
community and outside and grounded in
the fact that x Mokena is one of the
main sources of information for the
general public about Ai.
So I think,
I think you're putting it right.
There is a big difference between the
sort of discussion we outta have within
the community and the sort of discussion
that really matter in the general
public.
So I think the picture of terminator and
Ai Loose and killing people and
superintelligence that's going to
destroy us.
Whatever we try isn't really so useful
for the public discussion because,
uh,
for the public discussion,
the things I believe really matter are
the short term and medium term,
very likely negative impacts of ai on
society,
whether it's from a security,
like big brother's scenarios with face
recognition or killer robots or the
impact on the job market or a
concentration of power and
discrimination,
all kinds of social issues which could
actually,
some of them could really threaten
democracy.
For example,
just to clarify,
when you said killer robots,
you mean autonomous weapon weapon
system,
terminator.
That's right.
I think
these,
uh,
short and medium term concerns should be
important parts of the public debate.
Now,
existential risk for me is a very
unlikely consideration,
but it's still worth a academic
investigation and the same way that you
could say,
should we study what could happen if I'm
motorized,
you know,
came to earth and destroyed it.
So I think it's very unlikely that this
is going to happen in or happening in a
reasonable future.
It's,
it's very,
um,
the,
the sort of scenario of an ai getting
loose goes against my understanding it
police current machine learning and
current neural nets and so on,
and it's not plausible to me,
but of course I don't have a crystal
ball and who knows what ai will be in 50
years from now.
So I think it is worth that.
Scientists study those problems,
it's just not a pressing question as far
as I'm concerned.
So before continuing down that line,
have a few questions there.
But what,
what,
uh,
what do you like and not like about x
Mokena as a movie because I,
I actually watched it for the second
time and enjoyed it.
I hated it the first time and I enjoyed
it quite a bit more the second time when
I sort of learned to accept a certain
pieces of it as a concept movie.
Hi,
what was your experience?
What are your thoughts?
So the negative is the picture it paints
of science is totally wrong.
Science in general,
and ai in particular,
science is not happening,
uh,
in some,
hidden place by some,
you know,
really smart guy,
one person,
one person.
This is totally unrealistic.
This is not how it happens.
Even a team of people in some isolated
place will not make it.
Science moves by small steps,
thanks to the collaboration and um,
community have a large number of people
interacting and um,
all the scientists who are experts in
their field kind of know what is going
on.
Even in the industrial labs.
It's information flows and leaks and so
on and,
and,
um,
and the spirit of it is very different
from the way science is painted in this
movie.
Yeah.
Let me,
let me ask on that.
On that point,
it's been the case to this point that
kind of,
even if the research happens inside
Google and facebook inside companies,
it's still kind of comes out.
Isaiah's come out.
Absolutely.
Think there will always be the case with
ai is,
is it possible to bottle ideas to the
point where there's a set of
breakthrough to go completely
undiscovered by the general research
community?
Do you think that's even possible?
It's possible,
but it's unlikely.
Unlikely.
It's not how it is done now.
It's not how I can foresee it in the
foreseeable future,
but of course I don't have a crystal
ball.
And so who knows?
This is science fiction after all,
but,
but usually it's ominous that the lights
went off during,
during that discussion.
So the problem again,
there's a,
you know,
one thing is the movie and you could
imagine all kinds of science fiction.
The problem wouldn't for me,
maybe similar to the question about
existential risk is that this kind of
movie paints such a picture of what his
actual,
you know,
the actual science and how it's going on
that,
that it can have unfortunate on people's
understanding of current science.
And so that's kind of sad is an
important principle in research which is
diversity.
So in other words,
research is exploration resources,
expression in the space of ideas and
different people will focus on different
directions and this is not just good.
It's essential.
So I'm totally fine with people
exploring directions that are contrary
to mine or look orthogonal into mine.
I am more than fine.
I think it's important.
I and my friends don't claim we have
universal truth about what will,
especially about what will happen in the
future.
Now that being said,
we have our intuitions and then we act
accordingly according to where we think
we can be most useful and where society
has the most to gain or to lose.
We should have those debates and um,
and,
and not end up in a society where
there's only one voice and one way of
thinking and research money is spread
out.
So the disagreement is a is a sign of a
good research,
good size.
So yes,
the idea of bias in the human sense of
bias.
Yeah.
Uh,
how do you think about
instilling in machine learning something
that's aligned with human values in
terms of bias?
We intuitively,
as human beings have a concept of what
bias means of what a fundamental respect
for other human beings means.
But how do we instill that into machine
learning systems,
do you think?
So,
I think they're short term things that
are already happening.
And then there are longterm things that
we need to do in the short term.
There are techniques that have been
proposed and I think we'll continue to
be improved and maybe alternative will
come up to take data sets in which we
know there is bias,
we can measure it pretty much any
dataset we're humans or being observed
taking decisions will have some sort of
bias or discrimination against
particular groups and so on.
And we can use machine learning
techniques to try to build predictor is
classifiers that are going to be less
biased.
Uh,
we can do it,
for example,
using adversarial methods to make our
systems less sensitive to these
variables we should not be sensitive to.
So these are clear,
well defined ways of trying to address
the problem.
Maybe they have weaknesses and you know,
more research is needed and so on.
But I think in fact there are
sufficiently mature that governments
should start regulating companies where
it matters,
say like insurance companies so that
they use those techniques because those
techniques will probably reduce the
bias.
But at a cost,
for example,
maybe their predictions will be less
accurate.
And so companies will not do it until
you force them.
Alright,
so this is short term longterm.
I'm really interested in thinking about
how we can instill moral values into
computers.
Obviously this is not,
uh,
something will achieve in the next five
or 10 years.
How can we,
you know,
there's already work and detecting
emotions,
for example,
in images and sounds and texts and also
studying how different agents
interacting in different ways may
correspond to patterns of say injustice,
which could trigger anger.
So these are things we can do in the
medium term and eventually train
computers to model,
for example,
how humans react emotionally.
Uh,
I would say the simplest thing is unfair
situations which trigger anger.
This is one of the most basic emotions
that we share with other animals.
I think it's quite feasible within the
next few years.
So we can build systems that can detect
these kinds of things to the extent
unfortunately,
that they understand enough about the
world around us,
which is a long time away.
But maybe we can initially do this in
virtual environments.
So you can imagine like a video game
where agents interact in,
in some ways and then some situations
trigger an emotion.
Uh,
I think we could train machines to
detect those situations and predict that
particular emotion,
you know,
will likely be felt if a human was
playing one of the characters.
You have shown excitement and done a lot
of excellent work with,
uh,
on supervised learning,
but on a supervisor,
you know,
there's been a lot of success on the
supervised learning.
So yes.
Yes.
And one of the things I'm really
passionate about is how humans and
robots work together.
And uh,
in the context of supervised learning,
that means the process of annotation.
Do you think about the problem of
annotation of put in a more interesting
way humans
teaching machines is there?
Yes,
I think it's an important subject
reducing it to annotation,
maybe useful for somebody building a
system tomorrow,
but longer term the process of teaching,
I think it's something that deserves a
lot more attention from the machine
learning community.
So there are,
people have coined the term machine
teaching.
So what are good strategies for teaching
a learning agent?
And can we,
uh,
design,
train a system that's going to be,
it's going to be a good teacher.
So,
so in my group we have a project called
a bbi or baby I game where there is a,
a game at or scenario where there's a,
a learning agent and a teaching agent,
presumably the teaching agent would
eventually be a human,
but we're not there yet.
Um,
and the,
um,
the role of the teacher is to use its
knowledge of the environment which it
can acquire using whatever way brute
force to help the learner learn as
quickly as possible.
So the learner is going to try to learn
by itself,
may be using some exploration and,
and whatever.
Um,
but the teacher can choose,
can,
can have an influence on the interaction
with the learner,
so as to guide the learner,
maybe teach it the things that the
learner has most trouble with or just at
the boundary between what it knows and
doesn't know.
And so on.
So there's,
there's a,
there's a tradition of these kinds of
ideas from other fields and um,
uh,
like tutorial systems,
for example,
an Ai.
Um,
and and of course people in the
humanities have been thinking about
these questions,
but I think it's time that machine
learning people look at this because in
the future we'll have more and more a
human machine interaction with the human
in the loop and I think understanding
how to make this work better,
problems around that are very
interesting and not sufficiently
addressed.
You've done a lot of work with language
to what aspect of the traditionally
formulated turing test,
a test of natural language understanding
and generation in your eyes is the most
difficult of conversation.
What in your eyes is the hardest part of
conversation to solve from machines?
So I would say it's everything having to
do with the non linguistic knowledge
which implicitly you need in order to
make sense of sentences.
Things like the Winograd Schema.
So these sentences that are semantically
ambiguous.
Now the words you need to understand
enough about the world in order to
really interpret properly those
sentences.
I think these are interesting challenges
for machine learning because they point
in the direction of building systems
that both understand how the world works
and this causal relationships in the
world and associate that knowledge with
how to express it in language.
Either for reading or writing.
You speak French?
Yes.
It's my mother tongue.
It's one of the romance languages.
Do you think passing the turing test and
all the underlying challenges you just
mentioned depend on language.
Do you think it might be easier in
French that is in English and that is
independent of language?
I think it's independent of language.
I would like to build systems that can
use same principles,
the same learning mechanisms to learn
from human agents.
Whatever their language.
Well certainly us humans can talk more
beautifully and smoothly in poetry.
So I'm Russian originally.
I know poetry and Russian is
maybe easier
to convey complex ideas and then it is
in English.
But,
uh,
maybe I'm showing my bias and some
people say that about a French,
but,
uh,
of course the goal ultimately is our
human brain is able to utilize any kind
of those languages to use them as tools
to convey meaning.
Yeah,
of course,
differences between languages and maybe
some are slightly better at some things,
but in the grand scheme of things where
we're trying to understand how the brain
works and language and so on,
I think these differences are minute.
So you've lived perhaps through an ai
winter of sorts?
Yes.
How did you stay warm and continuing to
research?
Stay warm with friends with friends.
Okay.
So it's important to have friends and
uh,
what have you learned from the
experience?
Listen to your inner voice.
Don't you know,
be trying to just please the crowds and
the fashion and uh,
if you have a strong intuition about
something that is not contradicted by
actual evidence,
go for it.
I mean,
it could be contradicted by people
that not your own instinct of base title
everything.
So of course,
of course
you have to adapt your beliefs when your
experiments contradict those beliefs.
But you have to stick to your beliefs
otherwise,
and it's,
it's,
it's what allowed me to go through those
years.
It's what allowed me to persist in
directions that took time.
Whatever other people think it took time
to mature and you bring fruits.
So history of Ai is marked with these,
uh,
of course it's Margaret technical
breakthroughs,
but it's also mark with these seminal
events that capture the imagination of
the community.
Most recent,
I would say a Alphago beating the world
champion human goal player was one of
those moments.
What do you think the next such moment
might be for?
First of all,
I think that these so called seminal
events are overrated.
Uh,
as I said,
science really moves by small steps.
Now what happens is you make one more
small step and it's like the drop that
you know,
allows to,
uh,
you know,
that fills the bucket and,
and,
uh,
and then you have drastic consequences
because now you are able to do something
you were not able to do before or now
say the cost of building some device or
solving the problem becomes cheaper than
what existed.
And,
and you have a new market that opens up,
right?
So,
so especially in the world of commerce
and in applications,
the impact of a small scientific
progress could be huge.
Um,
but in the science itself,
I think it's very,
very gradual.
And um,
where are these steps
being taken now?
So there is unsupervised learning.
If I look at one trend that I like in,
uh,
in,
in my community,
um,
so for example,
in my line,
my institute,
what are the two hottest topics gans and
reinforced for planning even though in
the Montreal in particular,
like reinforcement learning was
something pretty much absent just two or
three years ago.
So it is really a big interest from
students and there's a big interest from
people like me.
So I would say this is something where
we're going to see more progress even
though it hasn't yet provided much in
terms of actual industrial fallout.
Like even though there's Alphago,
there's no,
like Google is not making money on this
right now.
But I think over the long term this is
really,
really important for many reasons.
So in other words,
agent,
I would say reinforcement learning,
baby,
uh,
more generally,
agent learning because it doesn't have
to be with rewards,
it could be in all kinds of ways that an
agent is learning about its environment.
Now reinforced learning.
You're excited.
Yeah.
Do you think,
uh,
you think gans could provide something?
Yes.
Some moment in,
in well
or other generative models I believe
will be crucial ingredients in building
agents that can understand the world.
A lot of the successes in reinforcement
learning in the past has been with a
policy gradient where you just learn to
policy.
You don't actually learn a model of the
world,
but there are lots of issues with that.
Um,
and we don't know how to model based
around right now,
but I think this is where we have to go
in order to build models that can
generalize faster and better to new
distributions.
Um,
that capture to some extent at least the
underlying causal mechanisms in the
world.
Last question,
what made you fall in love with her
official intelligence?
If you look back,
what was the first moment in your life
when you were fascinated by either the
human mind or the artificial mind?
Know when I was an adolescent,
I was a lot,
and then I,
I started reading science fiction.
There you go.
That's it.
That's,
that's where I got hooked.
And then,
um,
and then,
you know,
I had one of the first personal
computers and uh,
I got hooked in programming and so it
just,
you know,
start with fiction and then make it a
reality.
That's right.
You.
Ashley,
thank you so much for talking to my
pleasure.